nobody can make games forever but it's  still a bummer when you see a developer  you like step away I'm Tony and this  game spot news update is going into  retirement hit atakus ooh a hero better  known as sweary 65 has announced his  departure from access games a year ago  he said he'd be taking a quote short  break due to some health complications  from reactive hypoglycemia but he took  to Twitter again recently to let us know  he'd be retiring after all after the  initial tweet last year he expressed  interest in returning to game  development after recovering but his  plans now are a bit unclear sweary is  perhaps best known for deadly  premonition the video game equivalent of  Twin Peaks his most recent title is d4  dark dreams don't die so we'll have to  see what crazy ideas he comes up with if  he returns to stay up to date with  sweary and everything else in video game  land you're already in the right place